distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the Nobel week
dialogue I think we can promise a day
that will stimulate your thinking and
imagination Alfred Nobel had high
ambitions for his price he wanted the
prices contribute to the greatest
benefit of mankind today we are doing
this by organizing the first Nobel week
dialogue
the 20th century will clearly be known
as the information century how many of
you would like to have your genome
sequenced let them decide their own risk
they're the ones that have cancer not us
we've been modifying plants and animals
for over 4,000 years so this is a
general question that's shared by the
online audience from Mumbai to
Massachusetts the scientists have to do
a better job of educating the public
we've reached the point where it is the
difference between whether we deliver on
this scientific promise or whether we
have to explain to our children why we
fail I think it's a wonderful
opportunity for people in the community
to talk and have a dialogue about really
important scientific issues it's very
different to normally scientific
conferences where it's actually only
scientists the format in general I think
is unique
and it was definitely worth considering